die entdeckung wurde im vergangenen jahr
als riesige sensation gefeiert es ging
um die galaxie ngc 1052 tf2 die sich als
völlig rätselhaft und mysteriös
dargestellt hatte ein us forschungsteam
hatte nämlich herausgefunden dass es
sich hierbei um eine galaxie ganz ohne
dunkle materie
diese hatte alle bisherigen annahmen der
astronomie gehörig auf den kopf gestellt
doch jetzt stellt sich heraus dass die
entfernung dieser galaxie falsch
berechnet wurde handelte sich bei der
geschichte also um einen einzigen großen
irrtum kriegs um science fiction die
gibt's täglich neue sounds videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst ja
nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
ein komplettes rätsel alles an die es
merkwürdig hieß es von den beteiligten
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern im jahr 2018
auch hierbei klicks um science-fiction
hat mir vor einiger zeit über diese
sensation berichtet die selbst den
fachleuten die sprache verschlagen hatte
eine galaxie ganz ohne dunkle materie
ein wirklich äußerst mysteriöse phänomen
denn bislang gehen fachleute davon aus
dass sich galaxien aus dunkler materie
entwickeln astronomie teams wissen zwar
noch nicht wirklich viel über dunkle
materie doch gilt sie nach bisherigen
annahmen als eine art kit der sterne und
gas von galaxien zusammenhält doch die
stern masse der damals entdeckten
galaxie mit der bezeichnung ngc 1052 der
f2 betrug nach berechnungen des
forschungsteams in etwa ihre gesamtmasse
und somit war laut der fachleute ganz
einfach gar kein raum werfer dunkle
materie unzählige astronomische modelle
wurden dadurch in frage gestellt doch
nicht nur das denn diese galaxie ist
laut der studie aus dem vergangenen jahr
zudem auch noch in anderer hinsicht ganz
besonders die fachleute hatten damals
nicht nur postuliert dass ihr die dunkle
materie fehlt sondern dass sie sich
zudem noch durch eine population heller
und langsamer kugelsternhaufen
auszeichnet im märz dieses jahres hatte
das selbe forschungsteam dann eine
weitere galaxien aufgespürt die ebenso
wie die erste entdeckung ganz ohne
dunkle materie aus kommt auch diese
entdeckung sorgte für erstaunen der
fachwelt dazu der beteiligte forscher
pieter van dokkum mit nur einem
einzelnen system konnten wir nicht
hundertprozentig sicher sein dass wir
nicht zufällig von oben auf die
rotierende scheibe blicken und daher die
ware bewegung der sterne und galaxien
masse unterschätzen
dank der zweiten galaxie haben sich
diese zweifel praktisch aufgelöst dass
wir beide galaxien exakt von oben sehen
ist sehr unwahrscheinlich
doch solche außergewöhnlichen
entdeckungen werden in der
wissenschaftswelt im besten fall
mehrmals überprüft und so belegt oder
eben widerlegt dazu ignazio tonio ein
wissenschaftler des astrophysikalischen
instituts der kanaren
wenn diese entdeckung bestätigt wird
wäre das eine der wichtigsten
entdeckungen der extragalaktischen
astrophysik seit jahrzehnten doch zur
enttäuschung der fachleute hielt die
sensation aus 2018 der erneuten
überprüfung nicht stand im gegenteil die
aufregende entdeckung von damals ist
offensichtlich gar nicht so sensationell
wie gedacht der entscheidende fehler
liegt demnach in der messung der
entfernung diese wurde damals wohl
falsch berechnet und somit ist auch die
massen abschätzung fehlerhaft rodeo und
sein team haben sich auf fünf
verschiedene indikatoren konzentriert um
die entfernung der galaxie zu ermitteln
unter anderem dabei das verhältnis von
helligkeit und lichtfarbe und interne
helligkeitsschwankungen das ergebnis ist
eindeutig und zeigt dass die annahmen
von 2018 falsch sind damit liegt die
galaxie kann es falls 65 millionen
lichtjahre von uns entfernt sondern
lediglich rund 42 millionen lichtjahre
die fachleute hatten sich damals also um
ein drittel verschätzt diese 20
millionen lichtjahre die sich die
galaxie die f2 also näher an der erde
befindet haben entscheidende folgen für
das ergebnis aus 2018 das hatte trio
folgendermaßen zusammen gefasst würde
sie stattdessen eher liegen wäre ihre
stellare masse signifikant geringer dann
wären ihre merkmale die einer ganz
gewöhnlichen galaxie im klartext heißt
das also dass dieser galaxie keineswegs
dunkle materie fehlt denn dadurch dass
sie näher an der erde liegt als
angenommen verändern sich auch die
schätzwerte der experten und expertinnen
für ihre stella masse damit gemeint ist
der masse anteil der sterne und leuchten
gase also der sichtbare materie hier
kommt das astronomie team auf ein
viertel des zuvor errechneten kleiner
wird aber die gesamtmasse der galaxie
und zwar verringern
hat sie sich der neuen studio zufolge um
die hälfte im großen und ganzen steht
somit also fest dass auch in dieser
galaxie df zwei dunkle materie überwiegt
ganz genauso wie in den meisten anderen
sternen ansammlungen auch beispielsweise
unserer milchstraße dazu heißt es in der
aktuellen studie
damit ist ngc 1052 df zwei nur eine
ziemlich gewöhnliche galaxie mit
geringer helligkeit mit den revidierten
entfernungs werten verschwinden alle
anomalien der galaxie und ihrer
kugelsternhaufen auch wenn dieses
ergebnis sicherlich ein anderes ist als
von den fachleuten er hofft dennoch eine
wichtige erkenntnis mit sich korrekte
entfernungsmessung ist im bereich der
astronomie enorm wichtig acht falsche
mythen über masse hat sich ein stein
geirrt ein cooles video von raum zeit
lockt der zukunft also hier anklicken
anschauen und auf jeden fall raumzeit
lockt der zukunft abonnieren dass man
sich ziemlich also bis dann bleib dran